my father offered me a Ferrari I would
be able to keep with the Ferrari if I
removed my hijab
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a Saturday for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you will inshallah click the link and
donate what you can subscribe
this video is a video of a river
assistant whose father gave her an
opposal just so she can take off her
hijab on a half of that matter and look
what she said and once we watch this we
should ask ourselves a really important
question if we was given this option
what would we choose let's watch what is
the most interesting sacrifice you had
to make to keep your hijab okay that was
when I had gotten my divorce from my
children's father and my father offered
me I love fast cars he offered me a
Ferrari and I would be able to keep with
the Ferrari if I removed my hijab but
I really really really as much as I love
the Ferrari and I wanted it I knew this
is like a direct a direct thing Islam or
Dunya alhamdulillah I didn't get the
Ferrari yeah because my father
um he isn't a Muslim and while he isn't
hurting me in my Islam or keeping me
away from being a Muslim he would love
for me to go back to being a Christian
so guys it's a panologist imagine Bowen
sisters as Muslims ourselves the level
of tobacco you have to have to reject a
Ferrari or whatever is for that matter
Poland says in the Quran Believers are
those who exchange their lives in return
for Allah
basically those who this is talking
about obviously in the sense of uh War
onto all Etc you're exchanging mystery
you are sacrificing your life for a
righteous cause which is and in return
the subhanallah how many people have to
walk on enough this was just a major job
that was being asked we should all have
the attitude that if somebody came to us
ask yourself this question if somebody
came to me and said I will give you the
entire Earth that planet Earth will
belong to you and everything in it I
just want you to miss one Salah once
Allah or I want you to commit Haram how
many of us ask yourself a question we'll
say nothing and how fast would you say
no to this is very important because it
shows us where we're at with our Iman
well lie about sisters those who
sacrifice those who lose their Deen at
the cost at expense of will not only use
Estonia will also lose the hair after
because when you attain that Dunya
whatever if someone gave you the whole
earth in exchange of come to Haram that
know that never will the creation be
happy with you you will never be happy
enough Ferrari the Bugatti the holy
things that you have you will lose this
life and the Hereafter this is an
amazing example that shows you brother
sisters now Allah says in the Quran that
if you turn me back into religion Allah
will replace you with a group of people
a group of people who will love Allah
and they will love Allah and they will
not care about the blame of the
blamework blames yeah they will love
Allah will love them this sister is a
weaver coming from a wealthy family she
turns her back to it not only that she
goes through a divorce usually when
since God will divorce they have a
question you know their Muslim husband
or Islam with totality she is being
offered this maybe at her West where
she's her husband has left her or
divorce whatever for that matter and
then she's been offered this and she
says what no thank you imagine the level
imagine the better job that she is in
front of Allah and guess what still has
a happiness and Islam and imagine what
Allah has in store for her for that
sacrifice that she's done and every
single one of us do sacrifices
he had to do a sacrifice not sacrificing
his son but he had to sacrifice
internally that he's going to sacrifice
his son that was the first sacrifice he
done and that is why we're Muslims
because we submit to the will of Allah
by sacrificing the worldly desires and
Allah's Commandment that we obey and
patient upon the Commandment What a
Beautiful video we all got one of the
sister in this life in the Hereafter and
make us among those who have the ability
to say no to all of all the Affairs
whatever it is even if it's at the
minute displeasure of Allah
to establish a Masjid and Community
Center in Norway and they urgently need
your support this donation will be a
sadakhajari for you because every person
that comes a step closer to Allah
through your donation you and Ashana be
reaping the reward click the link and
donate what you can